ماذا يعني ذلك بالنسبة للمستهلكين في الوقت
الحالي ، لقد رأيت عنوانًا رئيسيًا في أكسيوس
يقول
إذا كنت تريد شراء سيارة كهربائية واحدة هذا
الأسبوع ،
فما الذي يتطلع إليه الأشخاص الذين يتطلعون لشراء
سيارة جديدة وسيارة كهربائية جديدة ما الذي
يحتاجون إلى
معرفته جيدًا؟  الشيء الذي تحتاج إلى معرفته هو
كما لو كنت
تقول أن هناك الآن حدودًا للأسعار ،
لا يمكنك الحصول على رصيد لسيارة
SUV تكلف أكثر من 80000 أو
لسيارة تكلف أكثر من 55000
وبأرقام تقريبية  إذا
كنت فردًا ولديك أكثر من 150.000
من الدخل الخاضع للضريبة ، فأنت لست
مؤهلاً لذلك ، إذا كنت في هذه المجموعة ،
إذا كنت ترغب في الحصول على هذا الائتمان الضريبي ،
فافعل ذلك الآن من ناحية أخرى ، تذكر  لقد
تحدثت عن شركات مثل جنرال
موتورز وتيسلا ليس لديها بالفعل
ائتمانات ضريبية على شركة تويوتا التي يتعين عليها بالفعل
التخلص منها بشكل تدريجي لأنهم وصلوا هناك
كان حدًا يبلغ 200000 EVs لكل
شركة مصنعة ، وقد وصلت Toyota gm tesla
بالفعل إلى هذا الحد وهم
إما أنهم يتخلصون منها تدريجيًا أو لا يفعلون ذلك
أفيهم جيدًا كما تعلمون في هذه الحالة ، لا
تحدث أي فرق ، بل قد تنتظر أيضًا ،
أعني إذا كنت ستشتري إذا كنت
تتطلع إلى gmev جديد
سيصدر قريبًا ، فقد تنتظر أيضًا
لأنك لا تفعل ذلك  للحصول على ائتمان ضريبي الآن على
أي حال إذا كان ذلك مهمًا بالنسبة لك